okay
hi there
here i am
listening to my korean
and sweeping because
i happen to be listening to assimil for
reasons that i will explain
and if i'm going to listen i have to do
something
and i found that when i listen to music
or to music when i listen to my language
what happens is i'm more useful around
the house
earlier i was cleaning the stove now i'm
sweeping in the kitchen because i want
to i want to be doing something while
i'm listening uh i don't just want to
sit there and listen
so
you know it makes me exercise more
uh do more things so that i can actually
be occupied while i'm listening because
if i have dedicated time i want to sit
there and read or review words
but when i'm listening i want to do
something else and so i'm more helpful
around the house so generally speaking
language learn language learning makes
you a better husband maybe
anyway see you later
hi there so day 26
a different day
um
i
spent a good hour linking creating links
uh
um
on some of the new lessons that i found
in the korean library preparing myself
for reading them on my ipad
and then you know i was following it one
of the things about studying on a
computer is that it's easy to get
distracted so every so often when i'm
studying on the computer i'll go over to
our forum at link for example to see
what's going on and maybe chime in on
one of the threads there
and someone made reference to
luca luca lamporiella who is i think
perhaps the best of the internet
polyglots
and uh he apparently spoke of an
epiphany moment and there was some
discussion as to whether this happens
uh when you're sort of at an
intermediate level or a an advanced
level and i mean i made the point that
very few learners reach what what
according to the european framework is
c1 or c2 in other words an advanced
level i think most people are very happy
to achieve a high intermediate level in
a language i think in all the languages
that i speak only in french do i really
consider myself to be advanced even in
japanese or chinese or spanish i'm a
good intermediate that's kind of where i
am and i'm happy with that that serves
all of my purposes i can read i can
understand i can enjoy myself and i can
even do business in fact i did business
in japanese for many many years and yet
i know very well that there are many
gaps in my japanese so i'm just a high
intermediate so that's fine so very few
people reach that you know advanced
level so certainly to me the epiphany
moment
when you feel comfortable and happy and
satisfied and you can do what you want
it comes at the intermediate level not
at the senior at the advanced level
however
then there was something about
lucca and how he learned polish and so i
googled luca
learn polish kind of or something like
that and up came this article where he
talks about how he learned polish
and there he said that he uh used asimil
which is his favorite assertive starter
series for any language
so that reminded me that i have
asimil for korean whoops i have assimil
for korean
so i thought i'd go and spend some time
with it
and which i did maybe a couple of weeks
ago i did the first half of the book
most of you know which i know in a way
and so i said i'll go and do the other
half the book and i'll listen and i'll
read and and so forth
so it was kind of interesting because um
luca likes assimila and he gave the
following reasons he says it has a funny
and entertaining dialogue
bilingual text phonetic explanation
progressive and easy to understand
grammar notes progressive and effective
exercises pleasant graphics and audio in
the target language only
so
today what i did was i decided i would
listen to
the this smell consists of four cds each
30 minutes long so that's two hours of
audio all in the target language that's
good
so the first two cds are too easy so i
took the second two cds
and then i started listening and as i
you saw in the earlier video if i'm
going to listen i got to do something so
i started cleaning up the kitchen
and then that didn't get me very far
so my wife's been after me to move some
furniture and move beds and stuff like
that so pretty soon i got roped into
doing all of that so i spent about three
hours
moving stuff
listening while doing it except when i
was moving with my wife i can't listen
while i'm working with her because she
doesn't like it
so we did all of that
then i had a little bit of a workout
had my bath then we had a nice dinner we
had some nice uh chicken liver as an
order
and then we had and we had a little soup
with cabbage in it
and then my wife is very good at buying
sort of fish ends bits of the neck the
stomach and all the sort of ugly
leftovers when they prepare fish for
other people and these are a less
expensive and b
delicious so we had that
and carmen had made a uh a pilaf with
brown rice which had mushrooms and
vegetables in it was phenomenal
and then we finished it off with little
gorgonzola and all the while we drank a
little bit of canadian red wine by the
way the wine from the okanagan
uh is it very very good like a cabriolet
from the okanagan was delicious
so after that all of a sudden it was
time for
our the only television program other
than hockey that i watch which is
downton abbey
so then we sat down and watched downton
abbey which we really enjoy i mean it's
it's really i don't know why but i love
it it's the only thing i watch so
basically that's all i did i did manage
to sneak in about
20 pages of reading
asimil but eventually what i'm going to
do with this because so then let's get
back to luca
you know most of what he says about
asimel is irrelevant to me
what my take on asimela is that first of
all the quality of the book the actual
book binding oops always get in the
wrong direction you got a little string
here to mark your place it's very good
quality you can bend it in any which way
and it's a very good quality book
but funny and entertaining dialogues i
had essie mill for russian it was quite
entertaining better than the average
book
the korean is quite boring uh but not as
bad as the other korean books i had
where they're forever talking about a
korean-american going to korea to learn
korean and stuff which is like
absolutely
terribly boring this is better
the audio quality is excellent
uh phonetic explanations i have no use
for because i just listened
uh the grammar wrote notes i don't read
because i think a lot of the other
material that i have with lots and lots
of examples is much better plus they
have
you know they have this phonetics script
the korean phonetic script the official
korean phonetic strip is useless i can't
understand it it's got eo for oh
oh i i can't use it i mean hangul is
phonetic once you get the hang of how
hangul works i don't know why you would
need it on top of which here in the
assimil version they have their own
funny
because the official korean phonetic
trip this is so hopeless they've come up
with another one for french people which
is even more hopeless so i ignore all of
that
i ignore the grammar notes because i
said because i have other sources with
more examples
less explanation more examples pleasant
graphics are irrelevant to me
uh exercises i don't do
so really it amounts to audio and text
and the inconvenience of sml is that it
doesn't give you these individual
translations of the words so the ideal
scenario for me would it take would be
to take assimil and import it into link
look up each word
find the uh
the uh hanja or the uh
chinese character where applicable have
them as lists of words and i can see the
relationship between these different
words because to me language learning is
about words and how words are related to
each other and so forth i'm not at all
interested in
uh the bilingual text i find it very
distracting to be reading here and then
reading there i just want to see the
words and work out the meaning in the
actual text so what i get out of this is
audio and text there's two hours worth
the first half of which now is not uh
you know interesting enough or
challenging enough for me but the big
thing too was
that six or seven years ago when i
studied korean
and i had bought this book at that time
and i had my other sources which i
preferred to use but then i'd go here
and listen and i couldn't understand it
and now i understand it although i'm
missing a few words it's clear to me is
that an epiphany moment i don't know but
it's content
two hours all right when i get going
like with russian
i would be downloading
more than two hours a day
i didn't listen to it all
i've interviewed interviews from echo
must be each
interview is 30 or 40 minutes long i
would easily take down two or three
interviews and during my driving i'd be
listening to them but that's when i'm at
a stage where i don't have to read
everything that i listen to so
you know
yeah i mean you need exposure here
there's two hours of exposure two hours
of exposure is not very much you need
tens of hours hundreds of hours
many hundreds of hours of exposure
before you get anywhere so assemble is
nice but it's just
one source of content to me that's all
it is it's a source of content it's okay
lots of disjointed phrases it's not
terribly interesting sound quality is
good so i'm going to do that for the
next day or two the the other advantage
of assimil for me at this stage is that
some of the stuff i'm doing uh voice of
russia and so forth is difficult so i
plow my way through it i'm getting
better it's nice to go back and do easy
stuff so assimil fits the bill
um and there you have it and now it's uh
hopefully i'm gonna do a bit of reading
before i go to bed
bye for now
just a final note when i said phonetic
script i was referring to a romanization
of korean obviously hangul is phonetic
but there is an official sort of
romanization
of korean which is unintelligible at
first glance for anyone who hasn't you
know studied that system
so my beef with asimil is that they
continue to present you with that
romanization plus their own
special romanization for french people
all the way through the book which just
clutters it up
they would be better off to have larger
script for the hangul and then rely on
hangul so i just wanted to finish with
that otherwise i think i may have left
the impression that i thought hangul was
hopeless humble is not hopeless hangul
is what you've got to go with it was the
romanization that was hopeless